good evening it's five o'clock I'm Mark
hosting and this is a special edition of
the NewsHour live from the central lobby
of the houses of Parliament as we
investigate the Westminster accounts
following the money for the first time
Sky News can reveal all the payments and
Gifts donated to MPS since the end of
2019.
Richard sunac says he fully supports MPS
being open about their finances as Sky
News publishes data on the outside
earnings
I think transparency is really important
and that's why we have a set of rules
and regulations in place to provide that
transparency for people and it's
important that those rules are adhered
to
critics say that the system lacks
transparency our investigation struggled
to uncover basic details about who is
behind some pretty major donations a
special report is coming up plus I'll be
speaking to the chair of the common
standards committee and also we'll be
hearing from labor and the conservatives
foreign
[Music]
good evening welcome to a special
edition of the NewsHour tonight I'm at
the heart of Westminster in the central
lobby of the houses of Parliament it's
the workplace of course for our MPS and
it's uh their finances we're focusing on
this evening as we try to analyze who
the top donors are to individual
politicians it's the latest phase of our
investigation into the Westminster
accounts plenty more on that to come
throughout the course of the next hour
but first within the past few minutes
the health secretary Steve Barkley has
been on his feet behind me in the
Commons updating MPS on government plans
to ease pressure on the NHS
we will block book beds in residential
homes to enable around 2500 people to be
released from hospitals where they are
medically fit to be discharged when
combined with the ramping up of the 500
million discharge funding
it will unblock which will unblock an
estimated one to two thousand delayed
discharge cases capacity on Wards will
be freed up which in turn enables those
patients omitted by emergency
departments to move towards which in
turn unblocks ambulance delays my second
investment today is more physical
capacity in and around emergency
departments
by using modular units this capacity
will be available in weeks not months
and our 50 million investment will focus
on modular support this year and we will
apply funding for next year's allocation
to significantly expand this program
ahead of the summer
this government has the audacity to
ttenham service levels when are we going
to
see
service levels from government ministers
in the entire government the NHS is in
crisis the biggest crisis in its history
it is clear to the staff who have been
slogging their guts out over Christmas
it is clear to everyone who uses the NHS
as a patient the only people who can't
see it are the government what has been
announced today is yet another sticking
plaster when the NHS needs fundamental
reform the front door to the NHS is
blocked the exit door is blocked and
there simply aren't enough staff
but I see political correspondent John
Craig has been following the afternoon's
development John tell us more about what
Steve Barkley's been saying and more too
about the reaction
well Mr Barkley's still taking questions
from MPS he's been speaking for more
than an hour now and as we've heard he
would face a pretty big powerful
Onslaught from wed streeting the shadow
Health secretary but also a real attack
from one of his own senior back benches
sir Edward Lee who said how come other
countries in Europe can doesn't have
these problems why are we leaving it to
the labor party to come up with a reform
uh that was disputed as you might
Imagine by Mr Barkley but he talked
about three uh particular areas where he
was going to make changes one uh
immediately supporting the system now
and that of course is this block booking
plan we just heard about secondly
taking measures to uh alleviate and
relieve pressure on the hospitals in
next Summer and Autumn and thirdly
talking about some more uh resilience
in the longer term so in immediate
measures being taken there were some
skepticism from MPS on all sides about
this idea to use residential homes but
earlier in the day Mr Barkley held talks
with Trade union leaders to try and
break the deadlock in the the various
NHS strikes that are happening over the
next few weeks well there was no
progress at all really despite the fact
that Mr Barkley told MPS in response to
Mr Mr streeting that he wanted to work
with the unions well they were all very
uh critical of Mr Barclay the RCN said
that the meeting was bitterly
disappointing and he was accused of not
really making any uh progress at all he
wanted to talk about next year
settlement rather than this year and
also increase productivity a move that
was slammed by some of the union leaders
so deadlock on strikes they go ahead but
some emergency measures announced by Mr
Barkley in the Commons but it was
branded a phrase we've heard in the last
few days from labor sticking plaster was
what labor claimed they were
okay John thank you very much indeed so
let's turn our attention to the main
reason we're here in the houses of
Parliament tonight trades unions the
state of Qatar and a little known
business in Hertfordshire are among
those who have given most to individual
MPS since the last general election Sky
News and tortoise media have launched
the Westminster accounts a major project
designed to shine a light on how money
flows into politics now we can reveal
for the first time all the money the
payments and Gifts external
organizations and individuals have
donated two MPS since the end of 2019.
it's all legal and all the information
has been publicly properly declared but
as a result of today's Revelations MPS
have been accused of failing to provide
sufficient transparency after our
investigation struggle to uncover basic
details about who uh is behind some
major donations our Deputy political
editor Sam coats has this exclusive
report
[Music]
the Westminster accounts a new way to
follow the money through our political
system giving you the chance to track
your MP and who gives to them yesterday
we revealed which MPS are the most from
second jobs and triggered calls for
change the more transparency the better
today the men women and businesses who
put their money into Westminster too
long just part of the punch and duty of
our politics they're paid by the union
Barons and they're and they're proud of
it the simple truth is that they are the
party for their tax Dodgers not their
taxpayers but the reality of who gives
to our MPS is far more complex than the
game playing suggests
foreign
tracing the network of donors to MPS in
Parliament has never been easy links
have long been obscured in a system that
was never designed to be properly
analyzed
now here's something you genuinely
haven't been able to do before you might
recognize these names they're the top
donors to political parties four big
unions who've given over 21 million
pounds to labor wealthy individuals Lord
sainsbury and JC Bamford who opened
their checkbooks for the lib Dems and
the conservative party but this is what
we've never been able to show you here
is who's been giving the most cash and
support to individual MPS over this
Parliament so since December 2019 again
some names you recognize two of the
biggest unions are the biggest donors
unite and GMB with some of the biggest
sums going to labor MPS on the left of
the party in fact over half of unite's
six hundred thousand pounds of donations
to individuals go to Just Three labor
MPS Rebecca Long Bailey Richard Bergen
and Barry Gardner but then this becomes
a story about what we don't know and to
tell it we're going to focus on two
companies in this list
the third biggest donor to MPS in this
Parliament is a little known entity a
Hertfordshire business called npm
connect they give well over a quarter of
a million pounds to just three
well-known labor MPS Yvette Cooper Dan
Jarvis and Wes streeting
such a big donor so little information a
company but it's not clear what it does
or where it gets its money it has no
website its accounts say there are no
employees two directors are listed but
no public route to contact the company
itself
we just wanted to understand who was
behind the donations and why they gave
the money so we asked the MPS themselves
Shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper who
received a donation of 180 000 pounds
from the company her office gave us a
statement they said was not to be quoted
Shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
said everything was declared in the
proper way Dan Jarvis said all of his
donations support his work as an MP not
the answers to the questions that we
hoped for
so we travel to Hertfordshire to the
company's registered address
hello there I'm from Sky News um we're
trying to get in touch with people from
npm connect this is the address for npm
connect Peter Hearn or Simon Murphy did
you know whether I can speak to them or
how I can contact them
do you recognize the names I'm talking
about
you look confused
have you heard of mpm connect accountant
yes have you heard of npm connect
you haven't heard of npm connect it's
it's registered address is here
have you heard of Peter Hearn
or Simon Murphy the two directors for
npm connect he's a registered here yes
we're from Sky News we're trying to find
out more about npm connect
[Music]
but you said you don't you haven't heard
of npm connect
[Music]
but why not we're just trying to find
out about mpm connect
okay so there we have uh two individuals
in there who say that they haven't heard
of Peter Hearn of npn connect uh and
shut the door when we ask more questions
no light being shed here just an
accountants firm where hundreds of
companies have registered themselves
this all completely permitted under a
system that allows firms as well as
people to donate but makes answers hard
to reach all a question of transparency
and bigger than one company or one party
there are examples in this leaderboard
where the data alone presents us with a
straight up mystery here is the case of
IX Wireless why would 24 MPS all
Northern Tories each be handed between
two and nine thousand pounds from a
small little known Northern Broadband
company
why would they do it and who's behind it
a new beginning
a new dawn
a New Horizon glossy promotional videos
promise a network for everyone an IX
Wireless of one high profile support
from government then culture secretary
Oliver Dowden appearing next to founder
Tahir masan for the firm's Blackburn
launch it really is going to provide
some of the fastest Broadband speeds on
the planet to tens of thousands of
people across the Northwest
[Applause]
not all locals were as impressed as the
government Minister many angry at the
sudden appearance of large polls put up
by IX Wireless in their neighborhoods
the company's website its accounts phone
calls to IX Wireless and its sister
company 6G internet based at the same
address offered few clues why the firm
should be donating in this way
we've had a bit of a brick wall because
they say it's company policy not to hand
the media the email address for the
Press office so we're just gonna have to
knock on the door
there's nothing identifying any company
whatsoever the floor looks pretty damp
that there's really no sign of life it
doesn't look like there has been for for
some time
no answers so I called the number on
their website they immediately confirmed
this was the right address
I'm calling from Sky News my name's Sam
case I'm just trying to get in touch
with
um somebody from lights Wireless to
answer our questions I'm actually
standing outside Rebel house and there
doesn't seem to be anybody here
she sounded unsure
are you inside Ribble house she said
there will be and that she'd find
someone to answer my questions then put
me on hold
after a while I was told there was
nobody who could talk to me
uh is anyone in there does anyone work
in there no answer she asked me for my
details and said someone would be in
touch the call never came
24 conservative MPS have accepted
donations from IX Wireless one has since
defected to the labor party Christian
wakeford described how he applied for
campaign cash to fellow MP and head of
the northern research group Jake Berry
when it arrived a month later they were
told to register it from IX Wireless
before you were told that the donation
had come from IX Wireless had you ever
heard of them I'd never heard of them no
literally the first time I'd ever heard
was that email saying this this is who
you need to uh to put against the
register for a donation
Jake Berry declined to answer what his
relationship was with the firm and its
founder to hear masan
the Westminster accounts project was
designed to show us who gives and help
us to understand why but in some cases
answering those questions is simply not
possible the current system does not
make it easy to follow the money and MPS
can choose to avoid the most basic
questions I think the basic Assumption
of most MPS is that if they're following
the rules that they've been told to
follow they've made their declarations
but I think there's a bigger question
here is that transparency actually
sufficient if an MP is asked for more
information should they feel that
actually that is something that they're
willing and able to give do they
actually know the answer to some of
these questions if they've taken money
from from a a company that they don't
necessarily know how that is funded I
think that's actually quite important
MPS tell us the rules on donations give
us transparency but just following those
rules has left so many questions
unanswered an absence of information
the most important donations go to the
most important people who have the
biggest sway over our lives leaders past
and present under the spotlight tomorrow
as we continue to examine what's in the
Westminster accounts
[Music]
we'll be talking to Sam coats in just a
moment but first the Prime Minister says
he fully supports uh transparency in
politics following the launch of the
Westminster accounts investigation so
far we've revealed for the first time
all the money uh payments and Gifts
external organizations and individuals
have donated to MPS since the end of
2019. the Prime Minister of ishisunak
says it's absolutely right that MPS
disclose donations and their outside
interests
I think transparency is really important
for the healthy functioning of democracy
is absolutely right that there's
disclosures around donations and outside
interests and transparency is a good
thing and I fully support it
is it right that secure the sons are
being given to MPS I think transparency
is really important and that's why we
have a set of rules and regulations in
place to provide that transparency for
people and it's important that those
rules are adhere to
let's get more then from our Deputy
political leaders Sam coats who is here
now let's talk then specifically about
donations how transparent is that system
in reality well I mean you watch the
film so we played just a few moments ago
and
one of the things about our system is
that it is perfectly legal perfectly
proper that individuals should be able
to give money through companies but the
question then comes that if MPS say the
system is transparent do we have the
right to know for instance who is
controlling the company making the
donations uh why are they doing that can
we ask them questions and and that's
where we came up against a little bit of
a roadblock because you have people who
absolutely properly follow the rules but
still you can't really get to the bottom
of what's going on and I think that
that's the issue that that really is at
the heart of the of the film and and
there is a bit of breaking news today uh
mark because as you saw in that film you
had donations from a company called npm
connect to three labor MPS about Cooper
West treating and Dan Jarvis and we
tried in the process of putting that
film together to ask them what was going
on and essentially we were rebuffed and
the vet keeper even gave us a statement
that she said wasn't for quoting that
sounds a bit silly in many ways it is
but but the point they didn't really
elaborate at all about what was going on
since that film has come started running
on Sky news this morning in the last
couple of hours all three of them have
put out a statement that actually do
take us quite a lot further uh Yvette
Cooper Dan Jarvis and where's treating
all revealed that an individual
businessman called Peter Hearn is the
owner of mpm connect that Peter Hearn is
behind the donations and that npm
connects they say completely adjustment
company it's an investment company so
there we have it those are the kind of
details that we were seeking that we
couldn't get um answers to when we
knocked on the door of the accountancy
firm where the uh where it's where that
firm is registered and probably more
importantly when we approach the MPS
themselves one additional detail uh
where's treating we understand went to
the same school as Peter Hearn I think
they're slightly different ages so at
different points but nevertheless
there's that link as well and and I
think my reflection on this would be
it's sort of taken them probably a
little bit of public embarrassment to
get the MPS to engage with our questions
I
I got a very simple question which is
what why couldn't they have done it
earlier
okay we're going to talk to Chris Bryant
about that in just one moment um but
just broadly speaking the reaction of
MPS who've returned to this place today
so you have uh the Prime Minister
talking about the importance of
transparency today kirstama talking
about the importance of transparency
yesterday some uh other figures perhaps
more effusively uh welcoming who are MPS
welcoming the Westminster uh account I I
think it's fair to say that there's been
a mixed reaction from parliamentarians
themselves
um in private quite a lot of them are
quite critical they say actually that
we're guilty of clickbait Journalism
this is uh uh contributing to the toxic
atmosphere of parliament because
essentially what we're doing is we're
putting big numbers out there and people
might think that they're taking these
sums in their pocket
actually I think I would argue Skye
would argue that what we're trying to do
is understand more clearly what's going
on things are very carefully labeled uh
in the public tool that you can you can
access but but more generally I think
there's a conversation about money that
sometimes MPS not actually your next
guest Chris Bryan but but some other MPS
perhaps shy away from and
um and that doesn't help the debate that
doesn't help public understanding and
it's in the vacuum that's allowed to
grow up uh that misunderstanding does
happen and it's that that we're trying
to challenge and to combat and and I
think what is interesting is that we
have done this exercise but I think a
little bit further down the track I
think some in Parliament want to do this
exercise as well I think some MPS want a
searchable transparent database in the
way that's guide using tools media have
produced this week it's difficult it's
hard we've shown it can be done
um you can't do it without breaking a
few eggs but but we had a go with a
public and transparent methodology and
put it all up for everybody to have a
look to criticize to have a play with
but I think what's really interesting is
this this starts to nudge along
parliament's process to doing it itself
that really would be that's the point I
mean the point to me is it's not a Witch
Hunt
um this stuff is properly declared this
is an attempt for more transparency it
is the point it absolutely exactly yeah
exactly so let's bring in Chris Brown
chair of the standards and privileges in
committing cold so just I mean do you
think that it is helpful to pull all
this stuff together yes in one database
yes to make it much more easy for the
voters to understand yes
and why then well done I mean I don't
know so my question then is if you think
it's such a good idea why haven't you
because or your committee or other MPS
done it before this we've been trying to
do this for the last two years I mean
every minute that I've been not every
meeting
um on the committee that I but since
I've been share there's one member in
particular Rita
um who has been endlessly banging on the
door of this and trying to get the the
ICT people here in Parliament to put
together a system that works so you can
look at everything you should be able to
see everything that relates to an MPS
um you know registration of interest and
everything that they have to that goes
to their constituency Association rather
than to them personally and so on all of
that my one the one floor I think in in
your version is that it doesn't have
anything from ministerial interests so
it looks as if
um back bench MPS
um are more involved in all of this than
ministers whereas in actual fact it may
be and that's partly because the
government is shockingly bad at
transparency they produce if you want to
look at all the ministerial interests
every year you have to look at 320
separate documents online and and we've
got we've had a similar problem about
that anyway
um so apologies that we've been slow
we've been trying to get the house to
make it its number one priority and it
is now and it was when we had a meeting
in November and I hope that by the
summer we will have a fully all singing
all dancing
um system but I want it to include the
ministerial stuff as well right I mean
because on the face of it you know MPS
are saying to us but it's already
transparent but when you delve into it
it's not really as Sam found with this
company mpm connect you know we couldn't
I didn't say about that when I saw the
one that you had x i IX Wireless but
this is a company I think donating
mainly to to labor MPS couldn't find the
staff or website I mean couldn't we
eventually found a secretary at the
registered office who said she'd never
heard of the two named individuals so
right when you delve a bit deeper it is
still difficult to get to the kind of
information that the public may want yes
and there's an argument to say
um that
um two things really first of all the
the registrar in the House of Commons
with whom you register you know if
you've been to an event or you've had
some outside earnings the registrar is
literally that just a registrar as
they're constructed and as their office
is constructed they simply register
things they don't have the power to
investigate the commissioner has the
power to investigate though that is
always predicated on MPS cooperating
with that process and there is an
argument to say
um that if you really want to make sure
that this is
um you know all singing all dancing and
all the transparencies out there that
then you need to give the registrar a
bit more power to be able to investigate
the other thing is
we could have a system where at the
moment what you do is
I've just had a book advance
I send an email to the registrar saying
that it's from such and such person I
received it on search and search today
it's so much time and so much money
and sometimes they'll come back to you
and say oh can you give you give us the
address and have you done this through
your agent or not
um but maybe we should actually have a
system where you do it all yourself
online so you're entirely responsible
for your own registration and then we're
seeing your declarations on screen now
you're quite happy with that yeah
completely I mean transparency is the
name of the game I I I I'm not ashamed
of anything that's on there well the
Seven Grand from Qatar well
um which um
get it no well I guess it's benefits or
it went on a triple no no indeed and
indeed I've spoken about this the trip
together I went to Qatar the Qatari
government paid for it the com the
standards committee which I share we're
looking at whether we should introduce a
new rule to say that foreign governments
can't pay for trips for um for for MPS
that that would might queer the pitch
with the relationship with the United
States of America as well but yes so it
was a trip to Qatar I wanted to go
because at the time they were the only
extract place from Afghanistan and I had
135 constituents or people related to my
constituents who were possibly going out
throughout that evacuation unit and I
wanted to try and help them
um but if I'm honest I hated the trip
um I think I wish I hadn't gone
um and in the end I think it's good for
MPS to have good relations with other
countries but maybe we should be paying
we the UK should be paying for it rather
than other countries right we've got a
couple of minutes left Sam do you want
to you might have to get this microphone
in yeah
is there a problem around disclosure and
transparency look the point is that MPS
can take money from companies right and
those companies can be quite opaque is
there an issue so two things take money
from companies that's that's a big term
so there's I I think your meaning
donations to constituent to constituency
parties and elections so that's not
money that goes into their own buckets
and I think it's important to
disaggregate these things out that's one
thing and of course I think everybody
needs to know where this money is really
coming from you may know in the Andrew
bridgen case recently this was really
quite a naughty problem about where the
money was actually coming from and we
had to delve into it and and of course
he will be suspended tonight for five
days from the house and for being
engaged in paid lobbying and the um is
it too easy for MPS to take donations
and companies and then for the company
itself to be really quite murky quite
indistinct very hard to trace the source
of the money and actually because of
that we don't really have the
transparency that we keep being told
that we do
um
I haven't come across that until you did
this so it's again it's a Well Done you
sorry I'm sounding really patronizing I
don't mean it that way
um I think transparency is in
everybody's interests and actually I go
back to the point I made earlier the
people you really want to know
um where the financial transactions are
are government ministers if they're
going off on we may well get around to
that well but but that's the bit that's
missing at the moment and because
they're the people who actually make
decisions all I do is I shout at people
who make decisions
yeah but we've spent months doing this
so we'll we'll know I've got a point
here maybe and it may be that the house
authorities need to come to you to look
at what we can use from from what you've
done right that might just
shortcut the system so that we can do it
more effectively and there is a no sorry
and I'm conscious I didn't fully answer
Sam's question of course it should it
should be it shouldn't be opaque
the whole point of the register is that
it should be absolutely clear and when
anybody engages in their business as an
MP if they have a financial interest
they cannot Lobby on behalf of that
financial interest absolute rule it's
been there since 1695 in the orphans
bill right and this the changes that are
coming in March and uh you know paid
work for MPS as parliamentary advisors
and strategists and so for all go does
but does that go far enough it could
probably go further
um I think some of us would like it to
go further but this is where we got to
with um because in the end the motion
has to be tabled by the government
um I I think that
um undoubtedly there are some people in
the country who believe that no MP
should have any second job of any kind
whatsoever
um I think I'm not sure that that quite
works because everybody then goes apart
from a doctor or a dentist or a nurse or
maybe a farmer if they're in a rural
constituency oh and of course it's fine
to write speeches and um articles or
give speeches and articles and write
books and things like that
um so we found it really really
difficult to come up with a better
system than the for me the key issue is
if you have any kind of financial
interest outside Parliament
do you abuse it or do you abuse your
position as an MP to pursue that
commercial interest because that is a
conflict of interest for me that is the
single most important part of everything
that I've wanted to try and sort of
clean up about and but you only get to
know that if you have full transparency
are not you know murky cloudy
transparency full unopaque
opalescent no that's wrong I don't know
what word but just find it I mean should
it be down to us and salmon the tortoise
and so you know to do this it should be
down to you yes
sir but what I mean this it could have
been done years ago
well
um I'm not sure I mean our register at
least you can go online and you can if
you type in Chris Bryant register of
financial interests it will all come up
and indeed I think um they work for you
has a version which keeps your previous
register as well online and there's an
argument for us for us doing that in the
house or so that it's all constantly
collated we've also changed the rule so
that from the first of March if you have
an outside interest you you can't that
that lasts as it were for 12 months
rather than six months at the moment so
we are tightening up the rules I'm aware
of our own calls for more tightening and
where Peter bottomley is here so um in
fact we could actually just talk now to
thanks very much indeed uh Christopher
yes thank you very much indeed uh Peter
bottomly thank you very much indeed now
you're well qualified to talk about this
as not because of all your sort of
donations so forth so I don't think
there are that many other I think it's
zero but you've been in the house for
what is it 40 or 50 years or coming up
50 years what do you think of this idea
that we have done to bring this all this
onto one database so that the voter gets
a better idea what's going on it's a
good idea to bring things together
like the house ought to do more of it
all the house Library can do it and when
it says so it's not generally from a
politician to criticize the media their
way around I think you've made a bit of
a hash of it
well for a start people who made
donations to help someone get electives
it's not going to be monitored MP it's
helping a mobile secondly I think it's
important that people are willing to
contribute to political parties and
political campaigns I think that for
example when you have a leadership
campaign whether a tour around a labor
one people need to be able to get in
touch with members where they get that
money from as long as it's declared as
it is I think you'll do better and in
fact if I think you'd have more time you
could look to the Electoral commission
figures and some of the mystery in some
of today's door knocking would have been
avoided but that that's part of some
television I think also you have people
who can make an all-party group look as
it's um odd and some are odd I can
accept that
if I went through my own entry I think
there are 23 Pages or paragraphs I'm
going to get a long way in discover I
had no donations to me or no outside
earnings you then go on to another six
pages before you found those active in
all party groups some of which don't
have any outside funding and then you
get the figure of two million to those
who do have outside funding without any
suggestion of whether things like the
old party group for sexual health or
trying to make sure there are fewer and
social diseases spreading yes or the old
party group on the lease Holden common
form which has no outside funding yeah I
think we'd admit as Sam knows better
than I would admit that enough it's not
perfect but it is probably better to try
and do it
I think I would pick up I think I would
if I may pick up on one very important
Point
um we absolutely in this talk you said
that we conflate today's donations to
constituencies
that they we make clear that is they
that donations do not not go into
people's pockets in this tool and that
you know donations are there in order to
support campaign
I'm not attacking it was the point that
you made at the start it could be done
but in the same way if you take an
article from the guardian on Saturday
about Johnson House the headline was he
was authoritarian P he helped make the
way for other student the fact he was
labored doesn't matter on this thing I
think that if you had said to each MP
you're not responsible for the guardian
if you said to MPS this is the
information here is the website to find
it and here's all the information
together rather than going through 26 or
24 pages if there's anything wrong here
is the phone number to ring or the email
address it'll make a number of my
colleagues happier I don't have any
complaints and even if I had interest or
outside I wouldn't have a complaint
either so I recognize the roles of the
media is to make available to all what's
known to a few or if it's known in
different places how you put it together
so I I accepted that and I welcome that
and I said yep you're doing that so
levels to make it easier for you
there are some other things where I
suspect that a little bit of simple
research or talking to another Fergie
like me could have helped make the thing
more practical and more useful to
listeners and viewers for example one
constituent as soon as the situent came
to me and said how much you paid well
I'm big time to say good go back to the
sky website you'll find the link where
it says 84 000 pounds if I took the full
salary so and there are all sorts of
ways one could make life easier both for
you as media to those who listen and pay
attention
I'll take both off there if you like I
can take you through my own entry which
I found and you tell me which bits are
relevant and who's going to spot the
ones that they come to it's not a
criticism you're trying to do a very
difficult job your criticism essentially
people aren't reading the captions is it
our fault that you think that people
should aren't reading the captions
if your elders would let you I could
actually open up the answer now and take
you through Page by page but my main
point of coming on is to say Well done
what you're doing is important the way
you've done it could be improved like if
you did that it'd be more useful uh for
your role in making information
available to people and also in checking
whether people like one or two foreign
governments are actually giving what was
supposed to be seen as freebies to go
somewhere interesting and pleasant
rather than doing some things which I
used to do which is go somewhere
unpleasant and dangerous and for example
you know I nearly got killed no Salvador
at Oscar Romero's funeral that was the
old party group on human rights uh all
party group if someone provided 25 000
pounds and that was one of the three who
went that was like Peter Boston who got
eight thousand pounds to go to Central
America well the fact that Martin Bell
was standing beside me at equal risk and
services cameras I'm described with that
too wouldn't come out so it's difficult
yeah key points I want to make is do
donate typical parties do be open and do
make sure all the information is
available to all right it's good for the
system good for those and so forth very
quickly word on second jobs
what do you think uh should be the
position on that
I think people misunderstand the second
jobs issue I don't have one at the
moment
um and it's on stage where I don't have
need to in my professional
qualifications are a bit out of date you
know I was a fellow Institute of
personal management a long time ago what
I think is you want to draw people into
politics more kinds of roles so I had a
phone call Peter Thurman when he's made
redundant bought two Machine Tools built
up an engineering business someone said
we need people like you in Parliament
and we certainly do should he have given
up the business he built to come in
should you have said to James Callahan
when he was in his later stages he was a
farmer you can't have a farm or Michael
Foote you can't have income from
royalties well I think is wrong is to
use the House of Commons role being an
NP as a hiring fair and go and get a job
because you're an MP and that should be
banned it is banned in most ways but to
say to people we don't want to be a
practicing lawyer or we don't want to be
a practicing dentist or we don't want
you to be writing books or we don't want
you to
anyway a third of government MPS are
ministers that's a second job so I think
that it's not simple I wouldn't go for
the make myself popular and ban them I
would say invigilate and let people know
about them in fact you could you could
say if you're going to be have a second
job in your election address put down
I'm going to continue working as a x or
y or Z okay okay well it's a good video
to come on I mean a few things you'd you
know have a look at but broadly it's a
good idea it's a good Enterprise
um you know what's coming ask they can
do it slightly better I'd help them get
my information for free
okay well listen thank you very much
indeed um you better get a labor view
Rebecca Long Bailey is right behind us
so um thank you very Sam stay with us
because um uh so um well I mean Rebecca
what do you think of the you know in
principle of bringing these things onto
one database I think it's fantastic I
think transparency is longer overdue of
course we've got our register of
financial interests but it only go so
far in shining a spotlight on where
donations come from and to what extent
MPS are remunerated for outside
activities yeah now we've got we will
very shortly have all your
um registered donations and so forth on
the screen most of it I think has to be
said I think you're 11th on the list of
my writing saying over 400 000 most of
it from the unions in in your case I
think momentum as well
this was for the leadership
um campaign I mean it's a lot of money
from the unions do you think broadly
speaking and they get value for money
they certainly do and I think it's
important to note that when we were
going through the labor leadership
campaign I wanted to shine a spotlight
on party donations and I asked all of
the other leadership candidates to
publish their donors list before they
were expected to do so by the party
because I think it's important for our
members and our constituents to
understand who funds these campaigns
because that shines a light on what kind
of MP you are and what kind of leader
you were meant to be in the future and
of course I was proud that all of my
donations came from trade unions and
labor members who believed in what I was
setting out as a vision they wanted
proper rights for workers decent living
wage and to tax the super rich fairly so
that we could fund our Public Services
properly and it's also important to know
on the issue of Trade union donations
that they are the cleanest money that
can be found in politics they come from
democratic member-led organizations the
same can't be said of certain other
donations that are made to various MPS
that come from particular companies or
particular individuals who have certain
private interests
individuals and companies is not clean
money I mean it's it's not to say it's
not clean money but it comes with
strings attached should we say so trade
unions donate to the labor party because
they set up the labor party it's what we
all believe in is a Trade union movement
for particular individuals and
particular organizations there could be
strings attached so for example Rishi
sunak received 530 000 pounds as part of
his leadership campaign over a quarter
of that came from oil gas companies and
Aviation individuals with particular
interests now there are no details as to
what they expected from the Prime
Minister when he became prime minister
but of course the question needs to be
asked as as to why we haven't seen the
real action required on the energy
crisis why action hasn't been taken it's
just stringently enough on the super
profits of big energy companies and why
we're not seeing the action on climate
change that's needed all right look I
just want to stick on this issue at the
moment and on second jobs Kia stammers
seems to be quite clear that he wants to
ban second jobs he doesn't seem very
clear about the
um instance of David Lammy who has money
coming in from speeches and media work
and so forth he didn't seem very clear
at all about
um whether he should be stopped doing
this work
so what is his view what is his view
what is your view oh my own personal
view I mean I don't receive any external
earnings outside my mp salary and I
think that being an MP is a hugely
privileged position to be in there
aren't enough hours in the day to do
your job as an MP properly let alone
take on a second job so I would ban
second jobs and I think Kia was right to
say that now in terms of ambiguity shall
we say there are arguments that are put
forward that certain individuals should
be allowed to keep up the professional
qualifications I was a lawyer I chose
not to do that because I wanted to give
my all to my job as an MP and I
sacrificed my old career to concentrate
solely on this one but if you're a nurse
for example I don't think there's a an
argument to say that you couldn't in
your holidays for example go in and help
out at your local a e department but
when that becomes a diversion to your
job as an MP it's not right so I would
go forward saying that we need to ban
jobs second jobs for MPS categorically
Sam just following up on that so do you
think kirst armor should tell David
Lammy to give up his media work his
speeches and his training well that's a
disc
ussion I don't think my first interview
was I don't think MP should have second
jobs at all
so we've got um
neighbor MP is saying well it's already
transparent but it quite clearly isn't
in the sense of this company IX Wireless
that is funding
um some MPS we've got the other one npm
connect
and they just don't seem to want to be
upfront about what they're doing what
the you know who are they
um we had to sort of almost sort of you
know rent fit from MPS uh today this is
a problem isn't it it's a huge problem
and that's why this project is so
welcome and I think what we need to see
going forward is a far more detailed
register of Interest where we see who
with donors are who are the individuals
are behind the companies making
donations and their reasons as to why
they're making those donations because
that's not often made clear and then
lastly what that MP or that party is
expected to do and what they'll use
those funds for okay so just one more
today Yvette Cooper Dan Jarvis West
Street it all came out and told us the
details that we've been searching
thankful for weeks about the company
giving to them why do MPS run away when
we ask about money the first time why
don't MPS be why aren't MPS more upfront
about the money men the businesses
should they should they pick up the
phone should they answer generous
questions well what what what why did
the vet keeper do you think issue a
statement that said this is not for
quotes I mean I don't know I can't speak
for forever or her office but certainly
I don't think any MP should try and shy
away from providing this information
it's hugely important and it's in the
public interest and I think if we had a
more detailed register of Interest which
went into further detail and provided
the people behind the company names and
the reasons for those donations and the
way that money was spent then I think
that will provide a lot greater Clarity
to the public when they were looking at
the activities of their MPS
okay Rebecca Long Bailey appreciate your
time thank you very much indeed Sam just
a quick last word from you
um so what do you make of what the MPS
are saying well I think what what's
really interesting is just a great big
sweep of of views you had Rebecca Long
bayley there basically saying ban all
the second jobs including David lammy's
you had Peter bottomly saying look it's
important to have a diversity of uh
thought of a diversity of occupation
inside the House of Commons and that's
the that's one of the big problems here
it's actually the subject of a very big
party divide the labor party in general
want tighter rules the conservative
party most of their uh uh most of the
outside earnings going to Tory MPS 15 of
the 17 million that so that's one of the
one of the problems here but there is a
sort of bigger cultural thing it's going
to be very I'm very interested to see
whether the project to do something a
bit similar to what we've done ever
actually comes to fruition by the House
of Commons because although Chris Bryant
might want it his standard committee
might want it there are people who are
going to be nervous about having our
kind of thing endorsed by by Parliament
so it's going to be very interesting to
see whether the attitude of MPS allows
greater transparency in the weeks and
months to come okay interesting stuff
Sam thanks for being with us and uh
here's the QR code that you will want on
screen now to use our tool and to
discover uh how much money your MP gets
on top of their salary along with any
others you may be interested in it's all
in the Westminster accounts from Sky
News and tortoise media
now this is a special edition of the
NewsHour I'm at the very heart of
Westminster today as MP's return in the
central lobby of the houses of
Parliament MPS have been accused of
failing to provide sufficient uh
transparency after our Westminster
accounts investigation struggled to
uncover basic details about who is
behind major donations the director of
The Institute for government Dr Hannah
White joins me now thank you very much
indeed for being with us and we've been
focusing Hannah on the issue of
donations today and while on the face of
it it's transparent when you actually
delve down into the detail and trying to
get more detail it's not so
straightforward
that's right and I think this is a
problem which is often the case with
theoretical transparency around
government around Parliament there's a
there can be an argument made or we put
this data into the public domain but
anyone who's ever sat down as sky and
tortoise now have with the register of
members interests and try to work out
even what uh the Declarations by an
individual member mean let alone being
able to compare across parties or look
cumulatively at the the activities and
the donations which MPS are undertaking
and and receiving will attest to the
fact that it is extremely difficult to
interpret and so that's why I think this
project which you've undertaken is is so
important but I think that the
problematic thing is that for years uh
the House of Commons has been saying
that it recognizes this and that it's
that it's going to do something about it
but it's never been a priority and so
hopefully this project can help put some
impetus behind actually those promises
being fulfilled
well that's the point isn't it I mean
it's one thing to do the database that
we and taught us have managed to do over
the last few months it's quite another
as Sam was saying there just at the end
for the commons to start doing something
about it in a meaningful way and you
don't think I'm well he didn't think the
chances were that good uh it certainly
in the short term
but I think you've highlighted one of
the key problems at the moment because
there was an imbalance between the
parties in terms of which members are
are making the most uh from external
donations and external uh activities
with the the conservative party uh
members receiving the bulk of that money
and the labor party much less
while we have a conservative government
and a conservative MPS uh have a
controlling interest in all the
Committees of the House of Commons who
determine um questions like this uh the
chances of this being prioritized for
change are are less good than they would
be if the tables were turned and we had
labor governments and labor majorities
on those committees but I think there's
also some culpability here for the the
House of Commons administration because
uh you know the
the register of members of interest is
you know is is uh maintained by by
officials
um the digital capability to improve the
the machine readability the
accessibility of these uh entries that
MPS make is something that the House of
Commons Administration could choose to
prioritize and and to take forward
because it is something that has the
commons committees have talked about
doing but you know it seems clear that a
judgment has been taken that this isn't
a political priority and so that has not
been prioritized on the administration
side and I think that you know as I say
this culpability this political
culpability but I think the
administration could also have done more
to to say well this this has been
brought up by committees it's something
which we are going to invest in and take
forward
yeah I mean it's interesting you talk
about Labor we have found today some
labor MPS have been reluctant to give us
more detail more than they
um have to under current rules why do
you think it is that MPS on both sides
to be fair are reluctant to to offer
more detail
probably are hoping that you know even
if they have nothing to hide they feel
you know explaining themselves on this
sort of stuff isn't a big priority
they've got other more important
political priorities constituency
priorities and maybe if they ignore the
annoying journalists long enough they'll
just go away
um it's not necessarily that they've got
they've got something to hide it just
doesn't feel like a high priority for
them but that's why I think that you
know the effort needs to be pushed in by
the administration and the political
parties need to say look this actually
is a priority for us we want the public
to be able to access this information
which in periods in the public domain
but just can't be understood that easily
um and so so that is something that it
should be made a priority
um so that MPS don't have to think about
NPS don't have to engage individually
with journalists because journalists
members of the public anyone can just
look at either the sort of tool that
you've produced or a version of it as
you say by the houses of Parliament
which would just present this
information so it's not something they
have to to worry about
there is some tightening of the
regulations on the way as we were
discussing a little earlier with Chris
Bryant and you know MPS being paid to
act as parliamentary strategists or
Consultants is going to be
um against the rules do you think that
goes far enough or is there more to do
on that
personally I'm a I'm a little skeptical
that that really goes far enough I mean
yes MPS will not now take jobs which are
titles parliamentary strategist but
there are many ways to skin the cash in
many ways to draw a contract and at the
end of the day what the MPS have to make
sure they're asking is well why is this
this company the this uh individual
offering to to pay me a salary to pay me
an amount of money what is it that they
think they're getting from me and if the
answer is something which is by virtue
of my position as an MP uh then it's
it's probably not appropriate just
saying you know you can't take a job
with this title I don't think is far
enough my personal view is that there
ought at least to be limits on the
amount of time that MPS can spend on
outside interests where that amount of
time that limit is drawn is a political
question but unfortunately uh in my view
the view that the standards commit he
chaired by Chris Bryant took when they
considered this question recently was
that it was just too difficult to ask
MPS to record the amount of time that
they were spending on outside interests
and that that was too onerous and that
that therefore
couldn't be done
um my view is if they have the time to
spend on outside interest they should
have the time to document a time that
they're spending and where do you think
we'll end up on second jobs
so I mean I think you know as you say
the rules have just been tweaked around
second jobs uh I think that many members
of the public would be surprised at how
limited the change has been after the
Owen Patterson Affair there was a lot of
outrage about the amount of time that
certain members were spending on outside
interest in the House of Commons passed
a resolution to say it was going to
place limitations now I think most
members of the public
listening to that would have thought
that those limitations would have been
going further than just a restriction on
taking jobs entitled parliamentary
strategist and I think the next time a
scandal emerges in this space
um and and it will uh the public will be
further disillusioned when it discovers
that an undertaking that the House of
Commons gave to sort this out for itself
has been quietly shelved
okay uh Hannah White thank you very much
indeed uh for coming on this evening and
thanks very much indeed for helping us
uh with what we're trying to do
appreciate it so there we are is the
Westminster accounts it's on the Sky
News uh website much more coming up this
is the NewsHour and uh after six o'clock
we'll have more on the Westminster
accounts a major investigation into the
money flowing to MPS
[Music]